FIVE.
"THE FIVE."
A BATTLE OVER A CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION IN THE 2020 CENSUS IS
GETTING DOWNRIGHT NASTY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFUSING TO BACK
DOWN AFTER THE SUPREME COURT
HALTED THE MOVE AND NELL
NANCY PELOSI IS GOING AFTER THE
PRESIDENT WITH THIS MAYOR.
>> THIS IS ABOUT KEEPING, YOU
KNOW, THIS HAT "MAKE AMERICA
WHITE AGAIN," THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE, CERTAIN
PEOPLE ARE COUNTED.
IT IS REALLY DISGRACEFUL.
AND IT'S NOT THE FOUNDERS WHAT
THEY HAD IN MIND.
>> Jesse: TEXT LIKE THAT NOT
STOPPING.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION FROM
GOING FORWARD.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR SAID DOJ
HAS TO WORK AROUND TO INCLUDE
THE CITIZENSHIP QUESTION.
>> YES, WE THINK CONSIDERING ALL
THE OPTIONS, AND CONSTANT
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE PRESIDENT
EVER SINCE THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION CAME DOWN, AND I THINK
OVER THE NEXT DAY OR TWO, YOU
WILL SEE THE APPROACH WE ARE
TAKING.
I THINK IT DOES PROVIDE A
PATHWAY FOR GETTING THE QUESTION
ON THE CENSUS.
>> Jesse: OKAY, ONE WILLIAMS,
EXPLAINED TO ME WHY DEMOCRATS
DON'T WANT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO HAVE AN ACCURATE
READ ON WHO IS IN THE COUNTRY?
>> Juan: WE DO.
I THINK DEMOCRATS DO VERY MUCH.
I THINK THE CONSTITUTION SAYS
VERY CLEARLY AND THE ENUMERATION
CLAUSE, ARTICLE 1 COMMIT SAYS
CLEARLY THAT IT IS AN ACTUAL
COUNT OF ALL THE PEOPLE.
IT DOESN'T SAY CITIZENS, IT SAYS
COUNT ALL THE PEOPLE.
BECAUSE IT'S FOR REPRESENTATION
OF CONGRESS AND FEDERAL.
IT IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
BUT ONCE YOU START CHANGING AND
PLAYING GAMES, OH, LET'S COUNT
REPRESENTING THE FAMOUS BLACKS,
THREE-PHASE OR DON'T COUNT THE
INDIANS, THEY ARE NOT -- THEY
DON'T PAY TAXES TO INDIANS.
NO, WHAT WE HAVE UNDERSTOOD
SENSE FOR ALL TIME IS, COUNT ALL
THE PEOPLE.
THE ENTIRE POPULATION.
>> Jesse: BUT SHOULD GIVE YOU
A COUNT OF ALL THE PEOPLE.
IF YOU ASK THE QUESTION STILL.
>> Juan: KNOW BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS AND I THINK --
>> Jesse:
'S Jesse:
'S Besse:
'S BEFse:
'S BEFOR:
'S BEFORE WE SHOULDN'T ADDRESS
OUR PEOPLE, IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING?
>> Juan: THE IMPACT, JESSE IT
SCARES PEOPLE OFTEN THEY THINK
THE GOVERNMENT WILL USE THIS
APPEARANCE BEFORE IT SCARES
PEOPLE.
>> Dana: IT'S LIKE THE
ARGUMENT THEY ARE MAKING.
>> Jesse: AT THE CENSUS IS
SCARY.
IT IS SOMEBODY GOING TO COME AND
GET YOUR GRANDMA AND THROW HER
OUT?
SPACE >> Greg: THROW UP THE
GRANNY.
>> Katie: HISSED THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT RACE MAYBE WE
SHOULD STOP ASKING PEOPLE ABOUT
WHAT THEIR RACE IS ON THE CENSUS
WHICH MIGHT BE MORE RACIALLY
PRONE THAN ASKING IF A CITIZEN
OR NOT.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO DO WITH RACE.
SO THAT IS THE FIRST THING.
THE SECOND THING, THE
SUPREME COURT WHEN THEY CAME
DOWN WITH 5/4 DECISION THEY SAID
IT WAS LEGAL FOR THE JUSTICE OF
COMMERCE DEPARTMENT TO ASK THE
QUESTION BUT THEY JUST DIDN'T
LIKE THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
IT WHICH FOR CONSERVATIVES, THE
SUPREME COURT SAID IT WAS
RIDICULOUS.
THE LEGALITY OF THE SITUATION.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT ACCOUNT, AN
ACCURATE ACCOUNT OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE PRECISELY
WHAT YOU SAID, JUAN.
THE CENSUS COUNTS EVERYBODY IN
ORDER TO DISTRIBUTE POWER IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IN NANCY PELOSI IS OBJECTING
WHEN SHE SAYS IT IS TRUMP THAT
WHEN CERTAIN VOTERS AND ACTUALLY
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT AN ACCURATE
COUNT BECAUSE THEN IT WILL
DISPLAY HOW MANY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING COUNTED FOR
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP AND
DEMOCRATIC POSITIONS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
BECAUSE MOST OF THEM LIVE IN
BLUE PLACES.
BUT IT'S NOT ABOUT RACISM OR
ABOUT MAKING SURE PEOPLE ANSWER
THE CENSUS BECAUSE THEY ARE
SCARED.
IT IS ABOUT GIVING A POLITICAL
POWER BECAUSE THE CENSUS
ALLOCATES AND THEY WANT AS MANY
PEOPLE AS THEY CAN GET LEGAL OR
NOT.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND.
LET ME QUICKLY RESPOND TO KATIE.
KATIE IT'S NOT ABOUT ADDING BUT
ABOUT SUBTRACTING.
IF YOU COUNT EVERYONE.
>> Katie: YOU MEAN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WOULDN'T BE COUNTED
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.?
>> Juan: IN OTHER WORDS, THAT
IS WHAT THE 14TH AMENDMENT CALLS
FOR.
>> Katie: USED TO ALLOCATE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., WHEN THEY ARE
NOT CITIZENS OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Juan: THAT IS YOUR ISSUE
BUT I'M JUST SAYING --
AND THIS IS WHY THREE FEDERAL
JUDGES HAVE RULED AGAINST IT.
>> Katie: NO ONE IS SAYING
THEY WON'T BE COUNTED.
LET'S COUNT THEM TO SEE WHAT
KIND OF PEOPLE AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND DOING IT BY RACE,
CITIZENSHIP AND WE ARE ASKING
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT
REPRESENTATION IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., FOR AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND NOT FOR 20 MILLION
ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: I HAVE AN
INTERESTING POLL.
>> Greg: THAT WOULD BE
SURPRISING.
>> Jesse: TWO POLLS MET,
ACTUALLY.
>> Greg: ONE WASN'T ENOUGH?
>> Jesse: THE MAJORITY OF
HISPANICS.
>> Greg: SO IF YOU ARE AGAINST
US ACCORDING TO NANCY PELOSI,
YOU MUST BE RACIST.
IF YOU ARE AGAINST THIS COUNTY
WHICH MINORITY OR FOR, YOU ARE A
HOPELESS BIGOT AND THAT IS
DISGUSTING.
FIRST, THE OPENING SEGMENT IS
PART OF QUESTION WHICH IS A PILE
OF PAPER THAT VERY FEW PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT.
WELCOME TO A GREAT TIME TO BE
ALIVE, RIGHT?
IT IS NOT WAR, IT IS NOT
PESTILENCE.
IT'S NOT PEOPLE DYING IN THE
STREETS.
IT'S ABOUT THE CENSUS.
BUT THE BIG THING HERE THAT BUGS
ME AND YOU GUYS ACTUALLY ARGUED
THIS QUITE COHERENTLY, IT IS
JUST THE RACE'S MIRROR.
OKAY?
AND SO COUNTING NOW IS RACIST.
AND IS COUNT, HE GETS AN IDEA
FOR A BEER COME IS THAT RACIST?
IF YOU ARE FILLING OUT A JOB
APPLICATION IS THAT RACIST?
ANY TIME INFORMATION ASKED, IS
THAT CONSIDERED RACIST?
IT IS SO OVERDONE NOW THAT IT IS
BECOMING BACKGROUND NOISE.
AND I WILL MAKE A DEAL.
IF WE HAVE BEEN WITH THE LEFT OF
THE MORATORIUM ON CALLING PEOPLE
RACIST I WILL STOP CALLING
PEOPLE COMMUNIST AND SOCIALIST,
OKAY?
>> Jesse: I CAN AGREE TO THAT.
>> Greg: I KNOW YOU WILL COME
ABOUT ONE MINUTE, PELOSI IS THE
SEASONED PRO THAT UNDERSTANDS
WORKING WITH PEOPLE IN THE NEXT
THING, SHE THROWS ON THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE WHERE YOUR COSTUME.
IT IS LIKE GRANT PUTTING ON
SCHOOL SKATES TO -- HER HEART
WASN'T EVEN IN IT.
YOU COULD TELL SHE DIDN'T
BELIEVE IT WHEN SHE WAS SAYING
IT.
>> Dana: I THINK THERE IS A
REASON SHE WANTED TO DO IT
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T LIKE THE
COVERAGE FROM YESTERDAY.
THIS IS ABOUT THE FACT THAT SHE
HAS A FEUD WITH AOC AND THE
OTHERS.
AND THAT WAS THE A BLOCK WHICH
IS CLEVER FROM A COMMUNICATION
STANDPOINT, I KNOW HOW TO TURN
THIS AROUND.
I WILL SAY TRUMP IS A RACIST.
THAT UNITES WITH HER AND SHE'S
ABLE TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
I DO FEEL IF BILL BARR HAD BEEN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FROM THE
BEGINNING, THE COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT WOULD NOT HAVE MADE
THIS GREW UP AND THEY WOULD NOT
BE IN THE LEGAL JAM THAT THEY
ARE YOUNG.
HE'S DOING HIS BEST TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WAY TO DO THIS.
BUT THEY ARE LATE TO IT, AND WE
DO NEED TO HAVE A COUNT.
I ALSO THINK IT COULD TURN OUT
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
REPUBLICANS WHO WERE KIND OF
WORRIED THAT YOU MIGHT NOT COUNT
ALL PEOPLE AND DISTRIBUTE IT
THAT WAY.
NOT BECAUSE OF POWER IN
WASHINGTON BUT BECAUSE OF MONEY
THAT GOES BACK TO THE STATE.
IF YOU ARE IN A STATE THAT HAS A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY AND IF THEY AREN'T
COUNTED BUT THOSE ARE PEOPLE
THAT USE THE ROADS, THEY ARE ON
PUBLIC TRANSIT, FLORIDA,
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS MIGHT NOT BE SO PARTISAN
WHEN ACTUALLY GOLD GETS THROUGH
THE WASH.
>> Juan: LET ME RESPOND TO
GREG ON THIS RACE ISSUE BECAUSE
IT IS EXPLOSIVE.
>> Greg: YOU THINK SO?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I THINK THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS YOU SHOULD
HAVE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND AS FOR
YOU, KATIE --
'S BEFORE ARE SAYING IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL TO ASK AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT IF THEY ARE A
CITIZEN?
>> Juan: UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT TRUE!
>> Juan:
>> Jesn:
>> Jesse: YOU NEED TO GO BACK
AND RESEARCH.
>> Juan: THE 14TH AMENDMENT
CLEARLY SETS AND THE 14TH
AMENDMENT IS THE ONE THAT
BROUGHT BLACK INTO FALSETTO
STREWN SHIP SAYS WHOLE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN EACH STATE AND LET MEJ
PEOPLE IN EACH STATE AND LET MES
PEOPLE IN EACH STATE AND LET MET
QUICKLY ADD, THERE WAS A TOP
REPUBLICAN DONOR WHO SENT A
MEMBER TO CONGRESS SAYING,
HERE IS HOW WE CAN IN FACT DIMII
HERE IS HOW WE CAN IN FACT DIMIH
HERE IS HOW WE CAN IN FACT DIMIT
HERE IS HOW WE CAN IN FACT DIMIE
IMPACT OF NONWHITE CITIZENS
VOTING.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS WANT?
>> Jesse: OR WE CAN ACCURATE
READ WHO IS IN THE COUNTRY AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
GREG SAYS -- >> Juan: --
>> Greg: I WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE USE OF THE RACE'S MIRROR BY
NANCY PELOSI.
YOU THINK TRUMP IS A RACIST AND
YOU WROTE A WHOLE BOOK ABOUT IT.
>> Juan: THAT IS TRUE BUT I AM
TELLING YOU THAT THERE IS A
WHITE REPUBLICAN --
>> Greg: BUT YOU KNOW THAT IS
NOT RESPONDING TO ME.
YOU THINK BUT YOU HAVE NO FACTS.
SHOW ME FACTS THAT TRUMP IS A
RACIST.
GO FOR IT, GO FOR IT, START NOW.
>> Juan: I DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK TO CENTRAL PARK.